j'étais un trafiquant de drogue j'étais un arnaqueur c'est
comme si je ne gaspillais pas mes grammes
je ne gaspillais pas mes grammes de sucre en poudre
ou de fromage à la crème
[Musique]
c'est ce que nous appelons des compétences transférables
transformez votre agitation
[Musique]
je suis  je vais devoir franchir la porte, il
a dû sortir avec, donc le nom de
chef Fresh vient de
mon cousin, mon beau-cousin m'a donné ce
nom quand j'avais 16 ans, il vient d'un
film intitulé Freshers à propos d'un
jeune enfant  J'avais l'habitude de vendre de la drogue et de jouer
aux échecs et il était vraiment intelligent et sage
dans ce jeu. J'ai fini par devoir
travailler avec ce nom, on ne peut pas simplement
se réveiller et s'appeler n'importe quoi
[Musique]
alors j'ai d'abord développé mon
esprit d'entreprise  ce que j'ai considéré comme une
erreur en vendant des stupéfiants illégaux
dans ma ville natale de Pisco, à New York, en vendant
des produits de marijuana de cette nature. J'étais
plutôt bon en vente et en marketing. J'ai plutôt bien
réussi
dans le processus lui-même, mais ce n'est pas
quelque chose que je glorifie, vous savez, mon  toute ma
carrière dans le trafic de drogue, de 16 à 21 ans, ressemblait
beaucoup à mon expérience universitaire,
c'était comme aller à l'université, c'était comme si l'
agitation culinaire était l'école des
coups durs pour moi, alors ils m'ont appris
la vente et la gestion de l'argent, cela m'a
appris l'ambition, donc  ce super mode pour
moi pour l'entrepreneuriat qui n'est
que des hauts et des bas, des hauts et des bas, donc comme
je le dis,
transformez votre agitation si vous êtes coincé dans
un jeu de drogue, vous pourriez facilement passer
à la gestion de l'entreprise
et à l'entrepreneuriat
[Musique]
donc l'un des  Les
principales idées fausses que je ressens à propos des
personnes anciennement incarcérées sont
qu'elles ne peuvent pas changer la plupart du temps,
elles sont toujours
coincées dans leur environnement actuel, c'est
tout ce qu'elles savent, beaucoup d'entre nous peuvent changer
et je suis le premier.  Un exemple de cela
[Musique]
des endroits comme le fonds Doe m'a vraiment aidé en me
donnant une structure, c'était aussi un
produit de programmes d'entrepreneurs comme
Five Venture, je n'ai pas d'
éducation formelle dans une école culinaire et tout le
reste est pure passion et expérience de travail
[Musique]
donc je suis sur le point de vous emmener dans ma
cuisine fantôme où nous produisons
les produits nos gros produits délicieux
nous allons vous apporter un magasin
tout ce que nous faisons est préparé frais sur commande
c'est comme ces choses sont jolies mec
c'est un vrai  caramel, vous pouvez littéralement
voir les odeurs sur le visage des gens lorsqu'ils
mangent les produits et qu'ils
les consomment et à quel point tout le monde
devient heureux, vous savez
[Musique]
en ce moment, nous préparons la garniture au fromage à la crème
qui entre dans
nos fameux biscuits au gâteau aux carottes ou
quelque chose comme notre velours rouge ou notre
velours bleu comme ça c'est la clé
rien
rien c'est comme si je ne gaspillais pas mes
grammes
je ne gaspillais pas mes grammes de sucre en poudre
ou de fromage à la crème tout s'additionne tu
sais
nous incorporons aussi l'amour  dans nos produits,
c'est littéralement comme l'
ingrédient numéro un
[Musique]
attendez mais la symphonie juste là, vous n'entendez
aucun type de notes
appréciation
regardez ce visage,
donc beaucoup de compétences que je
transmets encore aux patriarches de mon
opération de trafic de drogue  c'est comme le
service client, je dois toujours l'obtenir pour
le vendeur bas pour le prix élevé, nous achetons toujours du
matériel en gros, j'utilise toujours des grammes, des
onces et des livres pour mesurer
les kilogrammes de mon produit. J'utilise une balance numérique
qui est super parallèle, vous savez.
et je suis aussi dans la cuisine à le préparer
comme à préparer le produit
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
depuis que j'ai reçu mon cadeau qui est la
pâtisserie, je suis allé dans les écoles primaires, les lycées, les
collèges, les cliniques du VIH,
les prisons juste pour être un  par exemple et
partagez simplement mon message sur le fait que c'est comme si je
venais d'un milieu où j'ai été
enfermé à trois reprises, je partais pour
purger une peine, mais je pouvais toujours découvrir
ma passion, qui est la partie la plus
importante, pas mal dans cinq ans
de libération conditionnelle, mon histoire  c'est simplement le pouvoir des
secondes chances et le simple fait de comprendre
qu'avec le bon soutien et les
bonnes circonstances,
les personnes anciennement incarcérées peuvent changer leur
vie et réussir.